a safe and effective vaccine  is our best chance to beat coronavirus  and return to our normal lives in the  past month  the european commission has been working  tirelessly  to secure doses of potential vaccines  and tomorrow we authorize a contract for  up to 300 million doses of the vaccine  developed by biontec and pfizer  this is the most promising vaccine so  far  and once this vaccine becomes available  our plan is  to deploy it quickly everywhere in  europe  every member state will receive a fair  share on a pro rata basis  at the same time under the same  conditions  we have already started working with  member states to prepare  national vaccination campaigns  we are almost there in the meantime  let us be prudent and stay safe